We're almost 20 installments deep into Nintendo's
Legend of Zelda series, not counting those
terrible CD-i games…
"It's awful.
Mayor Kravindish has been chained in the tower.
Oh, my cakes!"
...and we're still going strong.
Breath of the Wild brought in advance buzz
by the heart-container-ful, and when fans
finally played for themselves, they noted
its balance between originality and honoring
the overall Zelda theme.
But what some players likely haven't yet noticed
are the exciting connections to Zelda's legacy
sprinkled throughout the game.
Does Dodongo still dislike smoke?
Are empty jars still a weirdly rare commodity
in Hyrule?
Will we ever figure out what the deal is with
this guy?
Here's a look at a few small details in Breath
of the Wild only true fans noticed.
Location, location, location
Since its initial release over 30 years ago,
The Legend of Zelda has been all about the
lush landscapes.
And amongst those grassy knolls and spooky
caves are a few structures that stand out.
Easily one of the most recognizable is Spectacle
Rock, which first appeared in the original
1986 release, and has cropped up in later
installments as well.
The double mountain appears again in Breath
of the Wild, where it can be seen in wide-angled
shots from above.
But this time, the famous formation appears
on a much larger scale.
You might also recognize Ranch Ruins as Lon
Lon Ranch from Ocarina of Time, and fans will
probably get chills when they run into the
Temple of Time again.
Breath of the Wild calls back to those games
that came before it with a slew of other place
names as well.
Sure, they've shifted around a bit since the
8-bit days, but the names remain the same.
Even still, the definitive Zelda guide, Hyrule
Historia, has told us that this series splits
off into multiple timelines… making everything
even more confusing.
Tingel Island is a riff on of the flamboyant
finesser Tingle, who appears throughout the
series.
Toronbo Beach appeared in a slightly different
form in Link's Awakening, and Koholit Rock
is a clear reference to Koholint Island from
the same game.
Mido Swamp grabs its title from an obnoxious
character in Ocarina of Time.
And even more Breath of the Wild locations
are straight out of The Adventure of Link:
Rauru Hillside, Ruto Lake, and Saria among
them, all of whom were also revealed as characters
in Ocarina of Time.
And Linebeck Island takes its name from from
the cowardly captain in The Phantom Hourglass.
The secret language
An element of Breath of the Wild that has
left players scratching their heads is the
mysterious Sheikah language used on various
items, signs, and descriptions throughout
the game.
While Nintendo could have just given us a
lot of convincing gibberish, like some kind
of Sigur Ros song, these things actually spell
out words
It's not hard to find a translation key online,
and players have utilized it to decipher hidden
messages.
Most interestingly, one winding bit of text
that appears on the Master Edition boxed version
of Breath of the Wild reads, "The Hyrule Fantasy"
in reverse.
True fans know that's the Japanese subtitle
for the original Legend of Zelda.
The cool references don't even stay within
the world of Hyrule, however.
When installing new abilities to Link's Sheikah
Slate in Breath of the Wild, Sheikah text
scrolls down the screen.
Some phrases can be translated as "now loading"
and "do not turn off your [slate]," but a
hilarious Easter egg can be found in the sentence
that reads "All your base are..."
This, of course, is a reference to the meme-worthy
English version of Zero Wing, which abysmally
translated the game's original Japanese into
the jumbled-up phrase, "All your base are
belong to us" when it hit the SEGA Mega Drive
in Europe.
And, well, just in case you've forgotten,
this eventually happened:
(amazing Internet song playing)
Thanks, Internet!
Oman Au
The monks of Breath of the Wild have some
unique names, but one sticks out.
Oman Au is an anagram for Aonuma, and it just
so happens that Eiji Aonuma has been working
on Zelda games since Ocarina of Time.
He's currently the series producer and manager
of the entire franchise, so it's a small way
to immortalize a guy who's already a bit of
a legend.
The Old Man
One thing that isn't new in Breath of the
Wild is the Old Man, who's clearly a reference
to that other old dude seen in the original
Zelda, who gives Link his first sword...and
some ominous advice.
This cryptic character shows up again in Breath
of the Wild, again with a fire, and again
in a small cave.
Of course, it could be a simple coincidence.
Weird old men love caves, after all.
But then, Nintendo stacked another juicy Easter
egg in there.
The Sheikah letters pouring out of light beacons
you can place hold a hidden message that links
players all the way back to the original Zelda.
The secret words?
"It's dangerous to go alone."
Just look at the flowers
If we're talking literal parallels to elder
Zelda games, it doesn't get more literal than
this.
When viewing the Master Sword in Breath of
the Wild, shown on its pedestal in the game's
official E3 trailer, check out the flowers.
Now, compare it to where you find the Master
Sword in A Link to the Past.
Sure, it's just three well-arranged flowers,
but it a fairly clear-cut nod to the franchise's
history.
Whether or not it means something significant
is for forum-nerd arguments and YouTube commenters
to decide.
And speaking of the sword, Link's weapon-grabbing
experience in Breath of the Wild shares a
lot of similarities to his journey in A Link
to the Past.
You'd think he'd be able to tell a magical
sword from a piece of junk by now, but no.
Maybe he knows a guy who can tell the difference.
In Breath of the Wild, gamers can grab what
appears to be the Master Sword fairly early
on in the game, where it sits perched on a
tall rock formation.
In truth, it's a rusty buzzkill broadsword,
that'll break shortly after you use it a couple
of times.
In A Link to the Past, Link also believes
he's stumbled upon the actual Master Sword
in The Lost Woods, which is weirdly filled
with tons of dummy swords.
Link thinks he's found the for-real blade
when he pulls it up from the ground... but
it all falls to pieces when it's revealed
it's a total dupe.
Next time, just looks for the one that literally
shoots lasers, man.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!